the u.s president warns china of
consequences if it helps russian forces
in ukraine beijing blames washington for
the war and says sanctions will hurt the
global economy so what's china's
strategy on ukraine and will it hurt
relations with the west this is inside
story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fully bhattibo it's been nearly a month
since russia invaded ukraine and there's
been no sign of any de-escalation
russian forces have targeted several
regions in the last few days including
the besieged city of mario paul in the
south while the fighting rages on world
leaders are attempting to find a
diplomatic solution u.s president joe
biden and chinese leader xi jinping
spoke on the phone on friday for the
first time since the war began
washington is concerned about beijing's
stance on the conflict chinese officials
have refused to condemn the invasion
biden has warned of consequences for
china if it provides material support to
moscow but the white house hasn't given
details on what those consequences might
include
we have a range of tools that could be
considered and sanctions are certainly
one tool in the toolbox as they are for
other countries as well even if we as we
have not outlined specific consequences
and we'll we'll communicate those
directly to china and of course with our
european partners and counterparts
meanwhile china's ambassador to ukraine
has sprays the strength of the ukrainian
people in a message that was a slight
departure from the official line in
beijing ukraine state media quoted fan
shing wrong saying china is a friendly
country for the ukrainian people as an
ambassador i can responsibly say that
our country will forever be a good force
for ukraine both economically and
politically he says will always respect
your state and develop relations on the
basis of equality and mutual benefit
here's al jazeera's katrina u in beijing
now with more on the call between the
u.s and chinese leaders according to
chinese readout it says that uh
president xi jinping told joe biden that
both countries had the responsibility to
de-escalate tensions that fighting was
in nobody's interest and also he
repeated china's stance that sanctions
would not be effective in ending of the
war and would only serve to damage the
global economy that was already
struggling to recover from the pandemic
now we know for the u.s part uh that joe
biden emphasized that there would be
material uh costs or there would be
consequences for materially supporting
russia in its efforts to invade ukraine
although the us did not state what these
consequences would be
u.s officials have asserted that russian
officials have asked china for military
support from military aid in the form of
equipment um in in terms of helping to
uh engage in this war something that
both moscow and beijing have denied uh
president biden also went on to uh share
his own view of the war and put forward
the us and its allies efforts to stop
russia's invasion and presumably try to
get china on board with that however we
have seen no indication whatsoever that
he was successful in this and in fact by
the end of this call as long as it did
last we've seen no sign whatsoever that
china's position has changed
well let's bring in our guests for
today's inside story in beijing andy
mark a senior research fellow at the
center for china and globalization and a
professor at beijing foreign studies
university in washington lawrence korb a
former assistant secretary of defense
and a senior fellow at the center for
american progress and in
london zeno leone a lecturer in war
studies at king's college london and an
affiliate of the university lao china
institute a warm welcome to you all
gentlemen thank you for being on inside
story uh andy mark in beijing let me
start with you please um as katrina said
there in her report the call between
president biden and president xi doesn't
seem to have changed anything in either
leaders or either country's position
but you believe that this was a
significant and an important call why is
that
i do believe this was an important call
i think uh first of all the framing and
the western media uh really is uh
misleading and
uh really there being nothing more than
dutiful stenographers for the us
government
uh if you read the singha
readout of the call it makes three
points uh the first that both presidents
thought the call was constructive the
second point which is the most important
one is that both presidents will
instruct uh their people
to take concrete actions to
uh ensure that the china-us relationship
is back on the right track and finally
the issue that is urgent and consuming
the intention of the world is that
both sides also agree that proper
measures need to be taken to resolve the
ukrainian crisis and i think it's the
second point that's really important and
the key here is can the us muster the
political courage that is necessary to
honor the
uh decisions taken during this call so
this is why i think this was actually a
very very important call andy you talk
about the framing in western media of
this conflict i wonder how does chinese
public opinion view this conflict in
ukraine well you know on social media in
the past few days there seems to have
been a shift uh in in chinese social
media how are they seeing this conflict
isn't it bad pr for china to be
sustaining uh these ties with russia
right now when civilians are being
bombed
well i think we have to separate public
opinion in china from the official
position and public opinion of course
matters but what matters more i think is
the government's uh position on this and
this has been consistent uh all along
the china has
long said that it is on the side of
peaceful development
and
that i think a couple things i would
maybe question here that
uh
that it's a month in and russia still
has not backed down if we really
understand the
causes of this conflict they're complex
clearly there are heated
disagreements and of course violent
disagreements on both sides of this
question
but frankly
china has said that it is an impartial
neutral and objective
uh participant in this and not taking
one side or the other which i think is
the only effective path to a peaceful
solution uh larry lawrence kobe i'll ask
you uh about this in just a second
whether china is a neutral participant
but i want to get your thoughts first on
this call between president xi
uh and uh president biden uh this long
phone conversation they had is it a
watershed moment do you think as
andy does that this was an important
call
oh i think it was very important because
really
the ultimate uh future of what happens
in ukraine is dependent on both china
and the united states and so i think it
was important for president biden to
connect with president xi and explain to
him
what the united states would do
if in fact china provides
more aid
to russia because right now
at least according to u.s reports russia
is running out of evil ammunition and
even food for the troops and so if china
doesn't provide that then maybe russia
will be willing to negotiate with the
ukrainians who have already announced
their might pull back from their desire
to join nato
so
on the question of china's neutrality
that andy uh wasn't talking about there
is china do you agree with him that
china is it could be a neutral mediator
in this conflict
i think very definitely that china could
because china has very strong trade
relations with europe which is part of
this uh conflict they're the only
country in the world that really still
has influence on russia i think it was
very interesting that before putin
invaded he went to uh beijing to talk to
xi and didn't do it till the olympics
were over so it wouldn't distract from
china's
attention on the uh on the olympics yes
they they do have it the united states
its european allies and even some
countries in asia have all come out
against russia but if china continues to
try and help them it will be russia will
have less incentive to end this conflict
on a negotiated solution
okay zeno let me bring you into the
conversation uh and you know the
slight and subtle change in rhetoric
we've seen in chinese media uh recently
in the last few days at least
when it comes to the war in ukraine
they're focused on the humanitarian and
the refugee crisis the tweet also from
the chinese ambassador to the to ukraine
quite significant uh china providing
humanitarian aid to ukraine as well how
should we view this do you think china's
position is evolving uh and has evolved
since the conflict began
and i think since the conflict began
china's position substantially hasn't
really changed there was always great
concern and great emphasis on
the drama
experienced by ukrainian people and
emphasis on trying to find
a peaceful resolution
however at least on a public level china
continues to be on the side of russia
and of course
here
china is
a dilemma
which is
should should it go should it prioritize
economic interest or political interest
because if it was to prioritize economic
interest it was
it would obviously
try to um make its conversation with the
west with europe more productive
but actually china we know there's a
pattern right we've seen this pattern
during this crisis uh china normally
tends to prioritize long-term political
interests and china really needs at this
stage of its um grand strategic
trajectory a
a partner partners in plural and
certainly russia is one of those so i
think china china's position hasn't
substantially changed it's still on
defense uh concern for ukraine but
doesn't not ready to let russia go yet
okay let's take a closer look now at
china's economic ties with some of the
key players in this crisis and what's at
stake u.s trade with china has grown
enormously in recent decades and is
crucial for both nations the united
states imports more from china than from
any other nation in 2021 nearly half of
china's 3.3 trillion dollars in exports
went to the u.s and its allies that
number is far higher than its trade with
moscow which hit a record annual high of
more than 146 billion dollars last year
and trade between china and the eu was
worth more than 800 billion dollars for
the same period andy mark in beijing
zeno says a difficult balancing act for
china what are the options then for
chinese leaders
if this conflict drags on
well i think unfortunately uh
i think all indications despite
everyone's hope that it can be resolved
soon
uh will likely drag on
i'm not sure that it really has much of
an impact on
china's stance or its policy decisions i
agree with you know that i think that
really china's
stance despite some uh positive rhetoric
from the or statements from the
ukrainian ambassador as you said
uh really has not changed and the
economics of this
does not play uh that big of a role uh
the important thing here i think that
china's been very very clear is that
whether in europe or whether in asia
what it will not tolerate is any country
undermining the security interests of
other countries in the region and this
is a message that i think has been
delivered very clearly and resolutely
to the us most recently in this
call between the two presidents c and
biden lawrence corp do you agree with
this andy says the economics of this
don't play a big role
i think an issue that's more important
to china here is the whole question of
taiwan
because they see russia
claiming ukraine back to part of russia
the same way that they see taiwan as
part of china and that sort of goes in
combination with the economic interest
they have both concerns and i think
that's really plays in this in fact what
we hear from the call is when biden
started talking about ukraine china
started talking about taiwan so that is
very important to them not just the
economic consideration but i think what
biden made clear to them is these
economic consequences as you just
pointed out here with the amount of
trade with the u.s and the european
union could really have pretty severe uh
consequences for china what consequences
precisely would the the biden
administration be considering here would
the u.s go as far as isolating
china economically in the same way that
russia finds itself isolated and
sanctioned today
i think they would move in that
direction the real que and by i don't
think biden knows exactly now because
these obviously would have severe
impacts on the united states as well as
our european nation so that really is
the key question so it's really up to
china now as we say in the us the ball
is in their court they want to help
russia by providing ammunition right now
or they're going to maintain their
neutrality and then try and start
negotiation because remember
negotiations are already ongoing i think
china could play a positive role and
tell
russia you know you can come out ahead
with this you they'll recognize your
annexation of crimea there'll be more
independence in the donbass region and
ukraine won't join nato and you can
declare that a victory
they know your thoughts about this how
likely is it that china
could push russia to end the war and
withdraw from ukraine
so i think what we've learned from the
meeting between
baiden and xi and also in the last few
months and from this crisis is that
actually there seems to be a bit of an
epidemiologic
vacuum
uh where nobody is able to really stop
child russia and also we we need to
understand that the international system
of sovereign states it doesn't work
in a way that
you know somebody in beijing only
because china is a very influential
power can just pick up the phone and and
stop putting doing whatever he's doing
especially when ukraine is such a high
stake for
uh for russia
so on the one hand china is probably the
most likely um player uh to to be able
to uh achieve something meaningful from
a diplomatic point of view because the
eu nato and the us liberally cannot at
the moment on the other hand that
doesn't mean that
china has all this influence that many
people think and especially men in the
us
hopes that china would have on on
russia so um and this is also why china
remains on defense because perhaps he
wouldn't want to be seen as
interfering directly with the country
trying to stop it and then maybe failing
because that would have a negative
impact on its influence if china would
look like a great power that perhaps has
only influence over small powers but not
in a major crisis like this one
andy in beijing your thoughts about this
well i like lawrence's phrase uh that
the ball is in someone's court but i
would say that the ball is in the us's
court for two reasons
uh first that russia is nowhere near as
isolated as the united states or western
media would like to make it out to be uh
first of all let's look at india who's
very clearly said that they're looking
to set up a rupee ruble uh exchange with
russia to continue trading with russia
look at the opec countries for whom
russia has been a very crucial voice on
the u.n security council
uh pakistan iran uh so i think the
efforts to isolate russia really are not
going as well as the us is portraying
and this will be doubly if not triply
true for efforts to isolate china
because while what russia can do is
threaten nato and the us with nuclear
attacks
china is not only a nuclear power it's
an economic superpower so it will be
even more damaging i think to countries
like the us that would try to impose any
kind of economic sanctions right uh on
china let me ask you this
about this viewpoint andy that that a
lot of commentators are making right now
and that is president xi was banking
on on putin uh and and his own country
in china to form a unified strong bloc
against the against the west another
block against the west i mean a weaker
russia whether they come out victorious
from this war or not
i mean
would that not sit not sit well with the
cha with the chinese i mean russia
regardless of you know whether they win
in ukraine will come out somewhat uh
weaker from this conflict isn't that a
concern for china
well i think very briefly china's world
view uh is that it wants to see a more
just and humane order without any
country engaging in these kind of
power politics cold war thinking but i
think the more important point here is
that really the case what about the
issue of taiwan i mean that was top of
the conversation between president biden
and president xi taiwan the implications
for taiwan
sure well again uh taiwan is the
cornerstone of u.s china relations
because china sees this as an internal
matter and others around the world
perhaps don't but i think i want to
really emphasize here that there's too
much attention paid to the military
conflict in ukraine but in fact we need
to focus on i think where the real
battle is which is economic and what
about if energy prices food prices
double and triple
what is that going to do to europe we're
already seeing uh the early devastating
impact from three million refugees uh
come next winter if this conflict is
still going on and energy prices double
and triple food prices are increasing i
think this will uh severely test if not
shatter european unity and in particular
um
germany i think many analysts in the
financial world that focus on the energy
sector say that
germany really should be much closer to
russia than the us but it's taboo at
this point okay to question atlanticism
let's bring in i think we have to see
yeah we have to see indeed let's bring
in larry in washington dc larry your
thoughts about this how will this war
define first of all future relations
between the us and china but also
between china and europe lawrence gold
well i think it's going to have a great
impact i think our colleague from
beijing is right that there's going to
be severe economic consequences for
everybody involved they're also going to
be economic consequences for china not
just the united states and it's very
interesting that andy mentioned germany
because up until now germany had been
leading toward russia but after this
started germany not only canceled the
north stream pipeline but basically gave
offensive equipment to ukraine in other
words germany has ended its post cold
war opposed world war ii
uh policy of really remaining neutral
and is becoming more aggressive nobody
wins the longer this goes on i agree the
real question is can china and the u.s
come to our understanding that profits
everybody because i i think that china
would like to see a new world order in
which china and russia sort of confront
the united states and end the period of
u.s hegemony and that's going to be the
real question how does this end and he's
right the whole world doesn't support it
but i am really surprised that asian
countries singapore japan they have also
joined in putting these uh sanctions on
so it's really i think it's a pivotal
moment for the international community
here how this ends up because the
ramifications will go on for decades
okay zeno leone in london your thoughts
can china and the u.s come to an
understanding and what will russia's
success or failure in ukraine mean for
you know global security in the years to
come and the global economy so it's a
very beautiful moment for the world
order and first of all to answer your
first question the problems between the
us and china they go they're structural
and they go beyond this crisis we have
just forgotten about those problems
because now ukraine is on the front page
of every newspapers um why is a pivotal
moment for the world order the world
order is already
somehow experiencing a degree of
decoupling on the one hand the us trying
to move beyond the liberal order with
the
better world of joe biden decoupling in
some areas from china
china is trying to do exactly the same
with the common prosperity campaign the
westernization
so this crisis it's pivotal because it
might accelerate this trend this is part
of the coupling and so it's very
critical for us to to understand and to
see
where the partnership between china and
russia is going because if it holds
there might be um quite an important
acceleration of this trend of the
coupling where we will see two partially
detached spare of influence um the
chinese one still very much in the
making looking at the developing world
and the u.s one which will probably
include um
those countries those those few
countries that have joined in uh
imposing sanctions uh against russia so
australia japan canada and the eu all
right gentlemen thank you very much for
a very interesting discussion andy mark
great conversation
and zeno leone a great conversation
indeed thank you very much
and uh thank you for watching you can
always watch this program again anytime
by visiting our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story and of
course you can join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me fully [ __ ] and the whole
team here in doha thanks for watching
bye for now
[Music]
you